the jurogan experience this was the
beginning of this book because i was
doing that i was looking at all the
ingredients that go into coca-cola and
saying okay
where what's in the drink first of all
because it's from my hometown that's
where it started i said okay i want to
find out all these natural resources in
the product
and you know is cocoa
in the drink
and also caffeine we'll get to that
that's how it gets to monsanto but um
cocoa was the most interesting actually
because i thought
you know it's called
coca-cola so does it have cocaine in it
um and so i went back to look at that
and turns out yeah you know trace
amounts back still in the beginning no
no in the beginning yeah but this is
what's interesting about the history of
the drink so
this is 1886 back then the coca leaf was
actually seen as something that was
medicinal medicinal innocuous absolutely
and everyone was using the coca leaf i
mean there was a drink called vin
mariani it was actually a wine a red
wine that was mixed with coca leaves wow
so it kind of had a little kick to it
and like queen victoria of england drank
this stuff ulysses says grant our
president was like woo you know coke of
wine this is awesome
and uh even the pope actually and i i
wonder if communion would have had you
know vin mariani we would all be
catholic or something but
um
but so it was really popular and this
guy this guy was down on his luck john
pemberton who started coca-cola in
atlanta
he wanted to make a coca drink himself
and so he made this originally coke was
actually a wine it was like a wine of
cocoa it was a red wine mixed with cocoa
leaves exact knockoff of that drink that
was really popular
and um
and then prohibition hits atlanta
because we're in the protestant south in
the 1880s and so he has to take out the
alcohol
and so he creates this non-alcoholic
drink coca-cola
that has the coca leaf in it they
weren't concerned about the coca they
were concerned about alcohol uh and it
remained in the drink uh throughout the
20th century what kind of dose
would it have in it
very small you know
and this i think is important you know
people equate the coca leaf with you
know cocaine because yes you can make
cocaine like street cocaine from
you know processing all these coca
leaves but if you go to peru today or
you go to certain parts of south america
people chew coca leaves it's a normal
practice it's been going back thousands
of years to the inca even um and so it's
very small amounts we're not talking
about like
in fact you'd probably get a bigger hit
from like
you know experience from a cup of
espresso from starbucks
but interestingly the reason that
cocaine became taboo and why it got
pulled from the drink had nothing to do
with national laws in the country which
was so interesting when i was studying
it it had everything to do with
racism actually in the south because
there was a concern that
cocaine was contributing to black crime
in atlanta which was being of course
blown up by segregationists and white
supremacists and asa candler who was
white guy in atlanta didn't want to have
anything to do with that so he decides
kind of quietly to take out the cocaine
but here's the interesting interesting
thing joe
they kept the coca leaf as one of their
secret ingredients yeah it it's so
secret ingredient number five by the way
cook doesn't like talking about this
this is not part of their history that
they like discussing
um but it's clear as day in the archives
you can see it so
it's called merchandise number five the
fifth secret ingredient in coca-cola
and i like the name isn't it merchandise
number five well the whole idea is that
you name things so that no one asks
questions right
what's merchandise number five
also that that ingredient includes a
little bit of the cola nut um
which is from uh west africa actually
and
it was originally in there because it
has caffeine another kind of caffeine
kick um that's where coca-cola comes
from but cola by the way is with a k the
actual color nut anyway that's
merchandise number five and it's
basically the flavor of the coca leaf
um
the essence of the coca leaf and the way
it works is these leaves are brought in
from
peru is actually where coca-cola sourced
it that was crazy i had to track down
okay where are they getting their cocoa
leaves from
and there's this company called maywood
chemical company today the company is
called steppen chemical company is that
new jersey it is in new jersey exactly
with new jersey yeah they're no they're
the ones who process it and they make
medical grade cocaine out of it and then
use the flavor aspect of it for
coca-cola exactly and
you know technically at first as you as
you put it most of the cocaine was going
for pharmaceutical uses and for you know
lidocaine all sorts of things like that
they use for legitimate purposes but
coke needed actually so much flavoring
think about their brand it's so big like
wheat grass juice you squeeze a lot to
get exactly the cup so they had to like
come up with this special i love it
you can't make this stuff up this is why
history is fun
there's a special exemption in our laws
for what are called special leaves
from peru and if anybody looking at it
saying well what the hell are these
special leaves you know and they're
special because they're allowed to come
into the united states exclusively
basically to create the flavoring
extract for coca-cola a lot of people
call it the coca-cola joker how closely
do you think they monitor that supply
you know i mean very closely they even
have to yeah if a bundle or two fell off
a truck here or there that could be
extremely profitable right i talked to
somebody once they said so is there like
a pile of cocaine somewhere up in new
jersey you know where this is happening
and uh you know i don't think that's the
case but here's here's the crazy part
too this is what's fun about tracing
these stories of ingredients because
they lead you to places you never
thought you'd go like this book which
we'll talk about but
um
it got weird if that's not weird it got
weirder in the 60s
because coca-cola wanted to figure out a
way
to
make coca leaves
in the united states to grow their own
coca leaves they weren't satisfied with
this trade with peru
and these are declassified dea documents
at the national archives this is not
like you know
yeah something crazy
you can see it and actually it's in the
book but basically
they petition the federal government to
start growing it at first they're
thinking like the virgin islands
but then they're like i don't know
there's like all these tourists it's
gonna be crazy but they have to find a
climate and a location geography where
they can do this
and they ultimately go okay
what about hawaii
and they do joe they grew coca leaves
secretly a totally secret operation
called the alakaya project
also called alike what does that mean
exactly nobody's gonna ask questions
you know obfuscate the the story
in kauai
oh wow and it was done through the
university of hawaii
they had to sign all these
non-disclosure agreements and they
wouldn't publish their papers
uh you know on the study of all this the
reason the government agreed to it is
that coke said we're going to create a
cocaine-less coca shrub
like basically breed a plant that
doesn't have cocaine in it
and
of course
that never really transpires but they do
end up growing secretly behind barbed
wire fences coca leaves for coca-cola uh
in the 60s
but i'm an environmental historian so i
study the relationship between like
businesses and the environment
and in this case the environment matters
because nature
bit back so
in the 60s this fungus
that's native to hawaii was like whoa
this plant
uh that's not native and attacks it and
it wipes out the entire
cocoa crop of coca-cola so that the
supply they had for a very brief time in
the 60s is wiped out they go back to
sourcing it from
peru watch the entire episode for free
only on spotify